I was gonna say I do feel like what's
dope about you is that it feels like
you're really kind of like
you know a lot of La artists like
they're a part of cruise or they're kind
of like really intertwined in the
industry as to where I kind of feel like
you're just kind of on your own Island
just making [ __ ] happen pretty much bro
it's it's it's all fictitious factions
that they create it's personas it's it's
cool you know if you have a manager uh I
do okay yeah I do have a brand new
um you know what's so funny
my manager kind of doesn't want to be
known as my manager right now you know
what I'm saying but it's like a Gentry
it's a secret no Gentry's not my man
okay no Gentry's my boy though Gentry
guy yeah yeah no Gentry's my [ __ ] yeah
but no Gentry is not my manager
um it's another cat though but yeah
Gentry kind of helps out he throws me
little plays here and they're like hey
you should do this you should do this I
love Gentry okay yeah I didn't know
because I was like yo like if it feels
like when you do your merch [ __ ] I'm
like yo is this guy just doing this by
himself I pretty pretty much yeah is
your girl help a lot kinda most of the
time she's just we just you know yeah
just arguing yeah and loving each other
and having sex and waking up do you feel
like sometimes you'll fight just for the
makeup sex
I no I haven't been that toxic but I
have you think she's that toxic though
or should be like just what is this and
then you never know yeah you never know
right you never know she might go to the
store buy a condom rip the [ __ ] open put
a cucumber in it
[ __ ] uh pull it out of the trash can
randomly and then just start to fight
with me and try to fight who knows and
then have makeup sex that's a wild wild
thing that just girls are crazy yeah she
hasn't done that yet don't get any ideas
what's her ethnicity she's Japanese and
Mexican oh that's the that's the one-two
punch bud man I'm telling you we got we
got we got Tapatio on the sushi at home
you haven't tried that yet have you I
mean my wife's Mexican and I've dated
Asians and lots of Latin women oh yeah
those are the two that you don't [ __ ]
with oh no [ __ ] no you end up dead she
turned up on me a couple times yeah
swung at me I had to back up I'm like
damn [ __ ] you know how to do Jiu-Jitsu
or something yeah it's crazy yeah for
I've never dated a white woman but I
always hear that white women are the uh
they're the most gullible uh
and like relaxed they are for sure
probably I've never dated a white woman
either but I know that white white girls
are chill as [ __ ] probably I I guess I
don't know I mean I could just I could
just picture it [ __ ] I come home from a
show
we live in Santa Barbara somewhere by
the ocean hey honey do you want me to
make you something you know what I mean
roll
High got Sugar Ray someday plant or
something like that she's
[Laughter]
the Sugar Ray you know what I'm saying
I'm in there now you know Zan he's she's
frying up some tofu and quinoa zucchini
or something and
I mean [ __ ] [ __ ] uh yeah Dawson's
Creek is playing I don't [ __ ] yeah
Sugar Ray oh my goodness no worries
[ __ ] no worries man